(inquisitive music)
- The cruise industry
is testing the waters
in its return in the U.S.
Cruise ships are currently
sailing at a lower capacity,
with many of these ships requiring
passengers to vaccinated.
But even then, there have
been COVID-19 case detected
even among vaccinated passengers.
So the cruise industry has
lost billions of dollars
since the pandemic forced these companies
to cancel voyages for more
than a year in the U.S.
And during that time,
they laid off thousands of employees
and curtailed marketing expenses
in order to stay afloat.
And for now, these operators
are slowly generating revenue
as they take in their first passengers.
(crowd cheers)
But they have also budgeted
hundreds of billions of dollars
in additional costs
for measures such as enhanced sanitation
and COVID-19 testing for crew.
So the cruise industry
has faced some challenges
as they return in the U.S.
And the first that they all
need to tackle right away
is to regain customer confidence
after having various
outbreaks on their ships
early in the pandemic,
such as the Diamond
Princess outbreak in Japan.
And to counter that,
they would have to employ
all these sanitation measures
and safety protocols
in order to reassure that their
passengers that are cruising
are safe.
(upbeat music)
(crew clapping)
(crowd cheers)
- We're back! Whoo!
- The cruise lines have been bound
to the set of guidelines
and recommendations
laid out by the CDC since October 2020.
And one way that they're able to sail
is to ensure that most
of the people on board
are vaccinated.
So even though
having at least 95% of
people on board vaccinated
is a quick way for the cruise lines
to resume sailings in the U.S.,
it's not that straightforward
because in one of the states
where they operate, Florida,
which is a major cruise hub,
there is a law in place
that prohibits businesses
from asking their patrons
for proof of vaccination
and these cruise lines
generally want their passengers
to be vaccinated.
As a result, this issue
has led to lawsuits
involving the CDC, the State of Florida,
and also one cruise operator.
Some key indicators of success
for cruise lines in the near term
is to avoid having massive
Coronavirus outbreaks on board
because that was one of the main reasons
why their sailings had to be halted
early in the pandemic.
The new Coronavirus variant
ultimately poses a risk to
the broader hospitality sector
and that includes cruise lines.
And their full effect has yet to be seen
on these first few sailings.
The timing for when cruise
operators could return
to pre-pandemic normalcy
is pretty uncertain.
Although cruise executives
have repeatedly cited
pent-up demand for voyages.
(crowd cheers)